c'est dans ces mille mètres carrés de
végétation que les papillons évolué
lasserre accueille ces espèces provenant
d'élevages des philippines du costa rica
ou encore de malaisie mais l'un d'entre
eux reçoit plus de faveur que les autres
ont préféré c'est beau grand noir avec
le bleu le grand jeu se passant monde
son nom c'est le morpho bleu un des plus
grands pensionnaires ici avec 10 à 12
centimètres d'envergure papillon bleu de
qu'ils se posent
il ferme ses ailes et une extérieure de
sézanne et mimétique par rapport à son
environnement et il ya également des
petits dessins dessus à l'extérieur qui
ressemble à des yeux il a un vol rapide
et l extérieur d elle est marron donc ça
se confond avec l'environnement et dans
les pays vit on l'appelle le je te vois
je te vois plus la série accueille
quotidiennement plus de 8 100 papillon
de différentes espèces et familles
chaque semaine 700 chrysalide sont
placés dans ces éclosent war puis
surveillé par les mamans de substitution
comme nathalie je suis grand mécène et
escaudain tune crise allait de cette
taille
je suis prêt à m'envoler un moyen
pédagogique pour parler de sciences aux
enfants et dès le plus jeune âge ils
sont déjà incollable sur l'insecte
c'est toi le site éparpillant la serre
aux papillons reste ouverte jusqu'au 11
novembre
chaque année près de 50000 visiteurs se
pressent pour voir les lépidoptères eux
aussi ravis de voir de plus près leurs
visiteurs